muy buenos días para todos ustedes pues
la verdad es que las informaciones nos
llegan en realidad a cuentagotas hasta
ahora pues sabemos que ya esa primera
parte de la reunión como usted bien lo
mencionaba ya se terminó una reunión que
comenzó sobre la 1 45 de la tarde hora
local y que pues luego siguió a esta en
la que estarán otros miembros de digamos
de la seguridad nacional rusa también
estará jake sullivan quien es uno de los
asesores a seguridad nacional del
presidente by denny también jon show the
banking es el embajador de eeuu en moscú
y que se espera que tras esta reunión en
algún momento pueda volver a la capital
rusa para continuar pues su trabajo y
que de hecho su homólogo ruso también
pueda volver a la embajada en washington
por ahora eso es lo que lo que se sabe
justamente en el momento que comandó
comenzó esta reunión se escucharon
algunas palabras del presidente by the
end que habló desde que se trata de dos
potencias y también de vladimir putin
quien le agradeció el presidente
norteamericano por haber tenido la
iniciativa de realizar
de reunión entre los dos países en el
día de hoy por ahora se sabe eso si
normalmente se esperaba que para la
conferencia de prensa quedarán al final
cada uno de los mandatarios solamente
los periodistas rusos podían estar en la
conferencia de prensa de putin y hace
unos momentos ya avisaron que en
realidad los periodistas norteamericanos
también podrán entrar a esta conferencia
de prensa que por ahora estamos
esperando pueda comenzar una vez termine
esta reunión